yourself
on the chat box and you know for us to
be able to know who's here
a little bit about your background and
interest
welcome kayla
thank you so much
we also have richa hello there
okay we're gonna start here shortly
okay we also have kurt
wagner from university of nevada and
we've got spandan jason welcome
everybody
okay so you hear me okay guys
all right so let's go ahead and start
all right so welcome to this overview
session on the summer 2022 omix logitech
virtual training programs
and the session will give you additional
details about their program registration
levels of complexity
desired outcomes that you might be able
to achieve over the summer
we have a range of options that you can
look into further and register by the
end of second week of june
and the programs we will be offered
virtually around the topics of coding in
r and python
infectious and chronic diseases as well
as a research project program that will
help you complete a research project
leveraging public domain data
big data infrastructure
and training and support from our
mentors
now because the ultimately the methods
that are best learned in the context of
real case studies prepared by our
network of mentors and collaborators
that illustrate how various
bioinformatics
methods and omix data types are used in
current research in medicine
biotechnology
agriculture and even astrobiology
the projects
are prepared by taking publicly
available data sets and using them to
explore and understand both the research
challenge and the analysis
path to extract meaningful insights from
conflicts on mixed data
the omislogic portal gives students
options for analyzing a given data set
codependent paths or code in independent
paths now these datasets and associated
publications can be used in several ways
you can learn bioinformatics without any
coding at all for that in each project
we explain the analysis pipelines on the
user-friendly t-bio info platform
for big data analysis
you can learn the scripts behind many of
the steps learning to wrangle clean
visualize and analyze data in popular
languages like r and python in order to
create your own analysis
finally you can hear about the projects
and their research applications in our
mentor guided programs where experts
share the experience and support
research projects developed by you
now let's start by signing up to the
learn omics logic portal
if you can please go to
learn.omicslogic.com
this educational portal will help you
get started on your bioinformatics
journey
i'll go ahead and post the link
bear with me
simply open any browser go to
learn.omixlogic.com
for those that have not signed up yet
feel free to sign up and
if you have any questions or issues in
signing up please feel free to reach out
now for those who have
already created their profile can you
please type yes on the chat box so we
can see um who already has a profile
that we have here on the webinar
okay perfect we have
nadder we have catherine ashley thank
you
we'll just give a few minutes uh for for
those people that have not signed up yet
to quickly uh create their account
and you will see there on the website
there's the quick sign in
using
google email your facebook
twitter account so feel free to use
those options as well
all right
now feel free to uh just put on the chat
box if you have any issues okay
now uh
once you have created your profile
we would like to encourage each and
everyone to update your profile in order
for us to track activity and issue
achievement badges and or certifications
now the complete profile includes a
profile picture
and you can add an avatar or your
university logo if you don't wish to add
your own
photo on there
connected social media accounts you can
use
facebook linkedin instagram and twitter
account
and a biography if you can please add a
brief bio about yourself including your
research interests
once you have signed up this is actually
what you will see on your um
on your profile page
um and there are four tabs
that i would like to discuss
we actually don't see your screen can
you reshare it please oh sorry
okay do you see my screen now yep
okay apologies for that
okay so
this is the profile page once you have
completed your profile you will see the
photo on there quick bio
and there are four tabs um in which we
will discuss
um as we go through the slides on the
activity tab is where we're currently on
right now now you will this is where you
will see um
for each activity that you are going to
complete as soon as you enroll or start
a program or a course
um
and then there's also the courses the
programs you will see there um
different tabs respect respectively
um on the programs that you are assigned
to and the certificates tab in which uh
where wherein you complete a
certain course you will be able to view
your certificate
and be able to download so
like like as i mentioned the successful
completion of a program you will be
awarded with a certificate
and you'll be able to access um your
certifications on your profile and this
is uh how it looks like
okay so after you register you will be
redirected to the course tab
and here you can search for any course
title and use the tags to find series of
resources around a topic
or choose one of the collections down
below
now in this video we will look at the
getting started collection
and i also would like to add that these
getting started courses are free and for
anyone who wants to get into the
bioinformatics
and you're welcome to share with your
network to take these courses
under the programs tab of your profile
is where you find the assigned programs
of your choice and each program has a
scheduled sequence of events and every
event has recorded sessions
and assignments designed around that
topic each activity you complete will
get points which are for completing
the course
running a pipeline and these points are
accumulated so you'll see here whenever
you complete a course it's 500 points
running a pipeline is 100 points when
you complete a profile is 100 and group
activity is for 10 points
in this program you will also be taken
through project examples on the
omixlogic project portal which will help
you understand the practical
applications of various omics data
analysis
and learn how it will be applied to
answer research questions in hand
finally designing your own
bioinformatics research project indeed
during this meeting you will be able to
learn about the upcoming training
programs offered by the national
association of the idea principal
investigators or nepi
on bioinformatics
we will focus on three programs
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
genomics and transcriptomic data
analysis to study viral and bacterial
pathogens as well as host immune
responses
transcriptomic data analysis for chronic
diseases such as cancer metabolic and
many others
bioinformatics using r and python
getting started with sequence and
structured data analysis in r or python
and in addition we will be sharing more
information about the omixlogic research
fellowship
a program designed to help young
investigators complete a full
bioinformatics project over the summer
and presented during our virtual summer
research symposium
to achieve this goal we use a
combination of online sessions
self-guided study materials and
practical assignments for an immersive
experience that has proven to be
effective in our well-known and
respected omixlogic programs
now talking in detail about the upcoming
summer programs i would like to invite
elia brodsky
el jabrowski has a background in applied
mathematics bioinformatics and
biomedical data science and he has
extensive experience in big data project
management in academia and industry he
is the co-founder and is the ceo of pine
biotech a company that develops and
commercializes data analysis software
solutions for life sciences
since 2014 the team under his management
is providing commercial and research
support to the numerous academic
projects
i'll pass on the stage to you alia thank
you
thank you very much um
so i'm going to share my screen
and briefly
what we will try to do in this portion
is describe first of all how to get
started
and then what these different types of
programs will include but i think that
we already did a number of presentations
about the general content and so if you
have any specific questions
and
maybe
you'll have some you know specific idea
about what you anticipate and you want
to make sure that that's what you're
going to be actually doing
um or if you have any other questions
feel free to put them in the chat i will
be looking at the chat and we'll try to
answer all of those
before we jump into this
i want to ask for hana if you have
anything that you wanted to share with
those that are from the
lbrn or lsu
students or faculty
and i will
unmute you
there you go
hello everyone
good afternoon i hope you all are having
a great day
um
can i share my screen elia
yep
okay let me know if you can do that now
okay can you see my screen
yes
okay
so hi uh my name is farhan abusarat you
all can call me for hana i'm the program
coordinator for the omixlogic lsu biomed
summer programs i'm basically a
molecular virulogist and working as a
postdoctoral researcher at lsu baton
rouge at the school of veterinary
science
and i will be assisting mostly the lbrn
and lsu members with registration and
any other issues that that they might
have
so these are the courses that we are
offering for the summer and elia already
described these courses
and
the question is who is eligible for this
course and the answer is it's uh
actually everyone
so this course is open to all
and um
anybody uh which is who are in lsu
usa or any other countries in the world
can take these courses and the courses
are available for a fee
however we are offering this free
registration for a limited number of
people
and the criteria is you have to be a
member of lbrn
or lsu school of veterinary medicine or
navy
lsu campuses members
are welcome to take the course also
however the course will not be free for
them
so how do we register for the courses i
have been getting a lot of emails about
registration process
and i need i think i need to explain it
very clearly
so the registration process includes two
steps
one is the pre-registration
and the other is the registration
so the pre-registration process includes
opening an account
in the omics lion omixlogic
portal which is the educational portal
and all your course materials will be
accessible there and before that you
have already registered for the program
in the edu.omicslogic.com
lsu biomed
so once you register here once you click
the register for the program here
you actually have
submitted the application to us and when
you open the account and create an
account and update your profile just uh
what
chaps and helia showed
you already
are in our system
however
for lsu and lvrn members only we need
additional steps to complete the
registration this step is not applicable
for navy
so for lsu and lbrn members only
for to complete the registration you
have to make sure that you have an
account in the ilab
so once you have created an account
there
you will have a login information
username and password and when you log
in here
you will see a drop down menu here on
the left top corner
you click here and then you will see the
core facilities
and then you will select the cedar core
facilities and services on the left
after that
you have to click on the
request services on the right side top
corner
so
after that you will see
training modules sections where you will
see all the names of the courses that we
are offering for summer
so in this training module with the red
asterisk mark you have to write down
what are the courses that you are
interested in
so you have to write down the names of
the courses in this red in this white
section
so once you are done
you you will see here a fun number
section
but you don't have to put any number
here
since the lsu and lbrn members will be
sponsored by us
so what you can write here
is just write whether you are from lsu
lbrn or lsu school of veterinary
medicine
and then just click the submit request
to core
and that is how you will complete your
registration
so if you have any other questions
regarding the registration process
please don't hesitate to contact me my
email address is i'm going to write in
the chat section
it's fmusa r1
at
lsu.edu
so i will try to answer any other
questions that you have or
you can write it in the chat section or
shoot me an email later on
and we will be happy to uh
answer and try to help out with the
registration process
so that's all
thank you yes i think there is a
question about the link for ilab um and
some other questions in the chat
so again uh i think rahana is going to
stay on and uh if you have those
questions she couldn't help you with
that
yes
all right great so again that was
specific to a
number of people um there are a number
of uh again free
licenses
especially if you are from nepy so how
do you know if you're a part of nepi
uh there's a website nappy.org
where you can see the map and all of the
23 idea states are listed on there if
you're from one of the academic
institutions in one of those idea states
you're most likely a part of nepy what
you need to check is whether that
institution is listed
because
nepi is an organization that brings
together pais funded through the
nih idea institution development award
so
uh if you receive this information from
your um
core
you probably have access to those free
licenses
okay so what i will try to do in the
next few minutes is briefly explain
how this training is going to be
different from what most of you are
probably used to when
it comes to
online
coursework like coursera
what are the specific benefits of taking
this training and how will you be able
to use some of the skills or resources
that you will
gain access to uh throughout the summer
so
first of all as already mentioned by
jabs in the beginning
we try to assemble training materials a
number of data analysis tools curated
project data sets so data sets that are
ready for analysis and interactive
sessions that some of them are going to
be available as recorded sessions or if
you're available during that time you
can join them live
and this is to make bioinformatics more
project based or oriented around case
studies
so
bioinformatics is a very broad
and dynamic field there's a lot of new
things that come up all the time
and so it's very difficult to
imagine someone kind of comprehensively
understanding bioinformatics is in only
three months and so that's why instead
of offering to kind of train you and
give you everything you need to know
bioinformatics we're saying this is
oriented around case studies how is
bioinformatics used in cancer studies
specifically using transcriptomic data
or how is bioinformatics used in the
study of infectious diseases for example
if we want to understand genomic and
transcriptomic data to study the
pathogen and to understand the host
responses right so those are the case
studies
for
again those of you that kind of work
already on some of those similar
projects this is the opportunity to take
your project and just analyze that data
as you go along
and that means that we're going to be
dealing with a diverse group of
individuals that some are faculty very
independent driven by maybe research
objectives and questions that they would
like to get answered as well as some
undergraduate students that might be new
to all of this and are just trying to
get started
and so that's why we're going to be
offering
a number of these different resources so
that you can explore the ones that you
need
on your own time but also have access to
lectures
and
mentors that can actually help you and
guide you and help you overcome
technical issues that you might face
so what we've done over the past few
years is we have collected industry
and academia lectures from a number of
organizations including different uh
nepi associated organizations and kind
of prepared a basic package and that
basic package includes genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
introduction to data science and
kind of a collection of different
project examples
in addition to that we understand that a
lot of people might come from a biology
background and they might not be
prepared for the technical demands of
both learning how to program a specific
analysis as well as setting up that
analysis to run
on a specific infrastructure like your
own laptop or maybe your core
high performance computer or something
like that and so because of that this
program comes with another important
resource called the t bioinfo
analytical platform now the platform
offers a semi-guided experience where
you have a number of predefined paths
that connect independent scripts into a
pipeline
and they come with a lot of
computational resources for example
every account will come with five
terabytes of storage uh you can also at
the end request for that particular
pipeline to be submitted into a list of
containerized pipelines that you could
deploy elsewhere
and most importantly you get a lot of
support so if you want to really
understand how it works what are the
parameters how do you change them how do
you run it for this type of data or that
type of data this is what the programs
are going to be about it is to provide
you with that kind of technical support
for example
how does this achieve learning goals
that we
are expecting to kind of arrive at after
this program
in many cases you are probably familiar
with
figures figures that represent analysis
like
statistical analysis maybe principal
component analysis or maybe differential
gene expression or you might be familiar
with uh mapping and visualization of map
breeds on a reference genome so the
platform will combine those kinds of
analyses into a
an experience where
every point in that process will be
color coded and will come with an
explanation so that you can understand
what you are doing
change parameters if need be and also
remember how did you achieve a specific
result so it makes that analysis
reproducible
now
in the program we will use both the
platform and then we will look at what
do some of these individual buttons do
how do they actually take in some data
that was already prepared for that stage
what type of data do they produce
what does that data look like and what
does the
analysis try to do how does it work
and so because we have multiple
comparison in each comparisons in each
logical step you will see how by looking
at the analogous analysis uh that are
available what are the differences and
how might you choose the right type of
analysis for your specific goal
i'm going to pause here because i have a
couple of questions i'd like to answer
so
uh question number one from analia if
you are not a part of any of the
fundamental programs how do you register
i will share again links where you can
purchase the program independently or
you can go to your pi or to your
university and say i would like to take
this training over the summer and a lot
of cases they will uh you know offer to
pay for that or maybe support you
partially
and the second question from ashley was
about this recording being available yes
this recording will be available after
the webinar and also it's going to be on
our
youtube channel
so as i mentioned beyond this logic it's
also important to at least understand
how code works and what are some of
those steps that you can take to get
started with coding in r and python two
two of the most popular languages in
scientific computing
so
what we will do is we will actually
use several of the examples
after the big data is processed and
we've kind of distilled it to structured
data or tables we will look at what is
the context so how do we ask questions
about a particular data
then what is the logic how do we
actually understand the steps to arrive
at a particular result then we will try
to practice and then hopefully that will
prepare you to be completely independent
both relying on big data analysis tools
which you will find many of those are
available today but also if you would
like to take your analysis further and
kind of take a look at um you know
becoming more independent and being able
to write such
analyses yourself
so now let me talk briefly about
three of the programs
so the first one i'll talk about is
biomedical data analysis using r and
python
this is a program designed for those who
are interested to learn how to write
code
so in many cases you will have a
particular
type of data that is already structured
and
for that structured data you either want
to
perform a statistical analysis
exploratory analysis maybe you would
like to
also use machine learning so that is
what this program is going to cover
first of all for those of you that are
not familiar with r and python at all
there's a way to get started right and
so what we've done on the portal is
we've taken some of the basic principles
like dealing with objects loading data
into
an environment where you can analyze
data
looking at specific
data sets and understanding structures
like matrices uh data frames etc so
those are the things that are going to
be covered in that introductory course
and that is available completely for
free if you haven't started with coding
we highly recommend it we'll help you
kind of extract meaningful insights out
of complex data visualize and present
them but beyond that we're also going to
go into
kind of a
high level overview of what data science
is and how is it applied specifically to
biomedical projects and here we will
have two tracks one is bioml in r and
biomel in python you can choose each
either one
and you will see
how these are used today when analyzing
complex data but also you will be
exposed to a number of standard or what
we call conventional machine learning
tools methods that are going to be very
helpful to deal with noisy data and data
that contains a lot of variability for
example patient data that contains a lot
of variability
so here is a brief overview of the
topics that we will cover
we'll talk about data wrangling how to
load transform and explore a data set
we'll talk about machine learning and
statistics what is the difference how do
they kind of compare to each other and
why high throughput data presents some
additional challenges for these methods
what is the general kind of
distinction between unsupervised and
supervised types of analysis
how can we use machine learning for data
visualization
then we'll talk uh exclusively about
clustering and another session about
classification
uh we'll talk a lot about how these
methods not only what types of methods
there are but how are they used in
example projects and we'll try to
address some biological questions that
you might have so for example
what is the bigger difference between
different tissues or is it between
normal and cancer tissue right so we'll
kind of use those methods to try to
connect it back to the types of
questions that you might have
then we'll talk about feature selection
and signature patterns how we can define
a particular signature pattern for
example a marker and then how can we
understand uh what that marker actually
represents uh what feature is it
connected to
we'll talk about regression and
generalized linear models and deep
learning um and and how deep learning is
used so all of these are going to be
covered
in a live session so kind of like what
we're doing today there will be someone
speaking there will be questions
questions will be answered there will be
some exercises but then you will also
have a number of examples and additional
projects that you can practice
independently
so what is that going to look like
here's an example of a course this is a
course on pca so how do you actually
produce a plot a three-dimensional or a
two-dimensional scatter plot to
understand variance in your data you go
through
first of all uh understanding the
problem you know why are you using pca
in this case then you will learn the
syntax of the code so how can code be
written to actually perform this kind of
analysis then you will be given that
code that you can run and you will be
able to modify outputs so in one case
you might produce a table and another
one you might produce a visual output
etc
then you'll be able to play around with
that code and know that you can modify
settings and this is very important
because in so many cases once you know
that there's a library that you can use
you just need to modify it to apply it
to your data and then make it do what
you would like it to do
it is a very liberating experience and
you can start going through a lot of
examples that people have posted online
and read that code understanding what it
was doing and know how to modify it to
apply it to your problem
and then finally once you go through
several examples like that you will be
given some
challenges
and those challenges will come as an
interactive notebook and they will
essentially be an assignment so you will
start with some beginning for example
you've learned the syntax you've applied
it to a particular data then the coding
challenge will say okay write this code
maybe there's a missing portion or maybe
write it from scratch
or maybe even apply it to a number of
different examples that are not trivial
they will need some thinking to overcome
some issues that you will have
and again as a result you will have an
interactive notebook that interactive
notebook will
be shared with your mentor and your
mentor will be able to suggest some
maybe technical issues how to overcome
them or maybe how to use other types of
methods for
whatever
challenge you are facing
now importantly we will look at some of
the ways that these methods actually
work and what needs to be done with
those methods to overcome common
challenges like missing data
maybe unbalanced classes we'll talk a
lot about evaluating the accuracy and
precision
how to trust your model how to deploy
your model after you've trained it all
of those kinds of questions is something
that we will focus on and kind of see
real world examples so what are the
outcomes of such a program the outcomes
of such a program first of all
some technical skills and kind of
reading papers looking at the methods
and knowing what they mean but also
putting them into a logical scheme so
that you can
kind of go from experimental design and
all the way to interpretation
through the lens of the analysis process
how the data is prepared for analysis
how is it explored to eliminate maybe
artifacts batches and issues with the
data how do they then perform actual
data analysis choosing between maybe a
model
that is statistical or maybe a machine
learning model and then how to produce
inference something that you can
interpret either in the context of that
particular experiment or something more
generalizable something that you could
kind of build upon to understand
something about the general population
so again what we will do is we will use
some case studies
and all of these cases are going to rely
on omics data so we will look at
diagnostics and cancer biology single
cell and tissue composition and we'll
also look at microbiome and infection
and you'll be able to choose
a number of curated data sets that will
be provided to you to kind of play
around with and develop a
project of your own at the end of this
course at the end of this training
program
so again if you have any questions about
this particular program any of the
topics that i just mentioned please add
them to the chat box i'd be happy to
answer any of those questions
and i'll just
give a moment here if anyone has any
questions
okay so again how do you register for
this particular program
the way you register is dependent on
which organization you're from so you
could be from three organizations
lsu school of veterinary medicine
uh
the second organization is lbrn
louisiana biomedical research network
and the third organization is uh
the
national association of idea principal
investigators
so
based on which organization you're from
uh if you were not present in the
beginning of the webinar kind of went
through all the different options how to
register but you definitely have to
create an account on the learn portal
and once you do please email us and you
can email to a number of emails here um
so for hana shared her email or you can
simply reach out to
this email right here
we'll be able to direct you on your next
steps and even have a call to discuss
your specific questions
okay so uh raquel is asking when the
course will start and end so this is a
summer program and so it's going to
start
june 15th all the way until august 31st
and extend it until september 15th so
you will have a full three months to
work through all of these different
things there's going to be a defined
schedule of live suggestions but all the
live sessions are going to be recorded
and all of them will be shared on the
program page and i will go over the
program page at the end of this
presentation
okay
so the second program is going to be
more focused on transcriptomic data
analysis or rna-seq and we're going to
talk about bulk rna-seq when you extract
your rna from the whole tissue
and you kind of analyze levels of gene
expression and compare them between
different groups or creating different
contrasts but we'll also talk about
single cell rnac when you extract rna
with a barcode that can make it uh you
know specific to a cell
and so this is an exciting field with a
lot of new methods that are becoming
available not all of them are simple to
use and in many of them you need to
use them
knowing how they were how they work so
how the data is prepared but also what
are some of the standard procedures and
considerations about the assumptions
that we have and about the conclusions
that we will have from our analysis
so we will talk about
uh first of all the biology of
transcription as a proxy for translation
how can we actually use
the abundance the quantity of rna of a
specific type
to infer
how this will turn into a specific
protein so this is kind of the most
common use case right we want to
identify
some functional state and we say that
the mrna is the proxy that allows us to
accurately
identify which genes are actually which
protein coding genes are being expressed
and that is why we think this leads to
some functional uh change now there are
several different methods to measure and
quantify rna but we will exclusively
focus on next generation sequencing and
for next generation sequencing there are
several levels that you can kind of use
that data to analyze what's going on so
one of them is just to look at genes and
these are protein coding genes
another one is to look at alternative
splicing events where you have multiple
exons that connect together and you
would like to understand how that leads
to different transcripts or different
isoforms so to say of the same gene
and so that oftentimes is a very useful
technique to be able to understand what
is actually going on because not in
every case
loss of function is associated with a
low level of expression for a particular
gene so we'll talk about the differences
between gene
and transcript level analysis but we'll
also talk about how to look at that
detail by making sure that we are
actually developing a transcriptome from
our own data and only then going through
the process of annotation
now we will try to apply this in the
context of a biomedical research project
and so we'll
talk about how
bioinformatics allows us to essentially
connect clinical and omix data
how it allows us to address questions
around diagnostics and
application of therapeutics so we will
kind of extend our understanding of
this expression of
genes either forms and proteins
translation into proteins to then ask
more biomedical
questions from the data that we will
explore
the program will have several different
sessions we'll start from just the basic
logic of what i explained how is that
processing done and what are the
important steps in that pipeline and the
important steps are going to be
how the data is prepared with minimal
artifacts so that our conclusions about
it at the very end are actually reliable
something that we can trust and so we'll
talk about different methods of
data pre-processing or cleaning
uh we'll talk about mapping how can we
map on the transcriptome on genome how
do we actually
identify those alternative splicing
events etc and then we'll talk about how
can that data be quantified and used to
represent a difference between
conditions so in the most simple
experiment you will have
several replicates in one condition
several replicates in another condition
and because they have been
kind of produced in a controlled way you
can you know make biological
interpretation based on these
differentially expressed genes and we'll
talk about plotting uh volcano plots and
things like that but also about
downstream interpretation how do we
connect those differentially expressed
genes with gene sets
like pathways gene ontologies etc and
how do we make sense of what's actually
going on
now to do that we will have to cover all
of the steps from the basic alignment as
you see here with the reads aligned to
the reference genome to then
quantification
analysis of variance
and understanding of whether it is the
right approach to be able to compare
multiple uh conditions and how do we
actually go about more complex data sets
where instead of just two contrasts you
all of a sudden have many
how can you analyze that kind of data
and that is again bringing us back to
that question of data mining and
classification really being able to work
with larger and more complex data sets
and extract meaningful insights by using
non-linear methods of
machine learning and and feature
selection
so then we'll also talk about single
cell transcriptomics so an exciting
technique becoming very very popular
many cores are now adopting 10x genomics
and other machines to be able to produce
single cell data question is what can we
do with it and how do we do it so that
we are in control of that analysis and
we know how to ask biological questions
and actually get answers to those
so to do that we will talk about uh
typical approaches so the standard
output being the umap or the t-sne
presents us with a clear picture
that unfortunately is not
trivial to explain because it really
contains a lot of information that has
been adapted to a
particular hyperplane and it's difficult
to connect back to biology so we will
look at how we can use such methods of
uh dimensionality reduction to start
asking biological question going back to
the statistical comparisons that we've
explored in the bulk rna-seq course and
how do we then can also ask additional
questions about for example pseudo time
how can we track trajectories where gene
expression levels actually represent a
continuous process then we will look at
the full pipeline again from
understanding of what is in our data to
then being able to ask specific
questions and then all the way to
downstream interpretation now all of
these are going to be given in the
context of several different project
examples and we'll talk about
patient-derived xenographic models where
we will compare tumor and the
micro-environment we will talk about
immune cells
and ability to understand different
subtypes of cancer we'll talk about
macrophages how
the complex immune responses
could actually be both
detrimental and
supportive of
tumor development
and we'll also talk about
early stage cancer detection like
biomarkers in exosomes so a number of
different types of projects that we will
look at uh we'll
offer also a collection of curated data
sets that you can kind of try to apply
some of the methods that we went over in
the program uh to something that is more
relevant to maybe your research
interests and we did call this
transcriptomics for
uh
chronic diseases so those are the types
of examples that we're going to use but
if you would like to then use it to a
data set of your own that is also going
to be possible and we have several ways
that you can do that including talking
to someone that can guide you through
that process discuss your project with
you and help you kind of arrive at those
results
so again if any questions about this
program happy to answer them now
uh if you have questions that you would
like to discuss after the session just
please email us hello at pine.bio we'll
schedule a time and we'll talk about
your project as well
the next program i would like to talk
about is called bioinformatics for
infectious diseases and this is the
application of
biomedical
data analysis to study
outbreaks for example of epidemics like
we saw in this pandemic
but also how to connect it to
genomic detail in the pathogen and an
understanding of how the pathogen enters
the host and what is the response of the
immune system
so again raquel to your question about
being able to access this recording
after this webinar you will receive an
email with the recorded version or you
can go and and look uh pine biotech look
us up on youtube and the recording is
going to be there on our channel
so um in the context of bioinformatics
for infectious diseases we will look at
a few different specific methods right
first of all we will look at sequence
variation and alignment how we can use
alignment to each other to understand
differences of genomic sequences between
themselves or how do we organize them
into groups using evolutionary and
phylogenetic analysis we will also look
at discovery of variance and association
between variants and specific changes
for example at the protein level or at
the population level and then finally
we'll touch on transcriptomic analysis
of host response primarily around uh
infected uninfected mock infected types
of experiments where we can understand
the host responses at the cellular and
tissue
level
so uh the beginning of the program we'll
start by kind of comparing and
contrasting infectious diseases with
non-infectious diseases we will then
talk about different pathogens
bacteria viruses
parasites and we'll talk about how they
cause disease what is it that we
actually call infectious disease how
does it manifest what are the specific
things that we look at and how can we
analyze those with different types of
molecular uh indicators and so that will
allow us to understand
uh
using again some case studies how
a number of different types of could be
used to characterize disease and
understand disease progression as well
as outcomes
and that will be uh kind of the main
idea of this program is it's multi-omics
data in the context of infectious
diseases
so
the
um
i think
the idea here has become
you know infectious diseases have become
one of those examples where these
advanced new technologies like next
generation sequencing have been used
extensively to almost in real time track
the development of an outbreak of an
infectious disease and also characterize
uh in very great detail how the
the pathogen interacts with the host in
order to
address that problem and create a
diagnostic
create a panel or a simple process that
could identify a very specific strain of
a pathogen that we now know better how
to deal with
also it has been used to identify
the types of vaccines for example that
we would like to design or an
intervention like an antiviral or a drug
that will interfere with that process of
infection
and so using these kinds of case studies
we're going to take a look at how does
that translate to actually understanding
the methodology what do we do with data
what kinds of data and how do we
actually practically make use of that
data to arrive at such conclusions
so again i talked a little bit about the
different types of methods that we will
cover and importantly it will come with
several different examples project
examples that you can uh try
saras cov2 genomics of course ebola
virus epidemic as well as malaria
infection and again this will be
primarily around genomic and
transcriptomic data
for hana i think parisa here has a
question on how to register in ilab so
if you could please share that with her
so finally i want to talk about a
program that is not specific to a type
of data or a type of an example but it's
more focused on the project that you
would like to complete during this time
and this is applicable to two types of
people so number one researchers whether
you are an undergraduate high school
student or faculty if your goal is to
perform research and you would like to
find a specific data set
analyze that data and come out with a
poster presentation or a publication
this is what this program is going to be
designed around
and the second example of someone is
maybe someone who would like to
understand the process of research so
one you know what kind of research you'd
like to do you have a goal and you know
how to more or less get there you need
the help with bioinformatics or the
second one you
don't know what research looks like and
you would like to understand how to
perform research but using
bioinformatics because maybe you don't
have access to a wet lab
or maybe you
are just trying to maybe do two things
at the same time
so the research fellowship is really
around the
process of
kind of determining what your research
question is
finding a data set that can help you
address your research question and then
being able to uh address uh you know the
kind of
question that you have with the evidence
identified in a particular data set
and the enablement that we offer here is
big data analysis infrastructure so we
will support your big data analysis
needs if you need to analyze a data set
with 10 000 samples and you don't
you know you can't do that in your
computer you will be able to do it here
mentorship so someone will work with you
to identify a question refine that
question make sure that that question um
could be answered with the data that
you've selected and then help you get
there and along the way we will provide
you with opportunities to train yourself
to be able to do this independently so
instead of this being training first
training is embedded into that process
because ultimately if you don't know how
to perform a particular type of analysis
you can just ask someone to do it for
you or here you will learn how to do it
on your own and be able to apply it to
that project
and we've selected a
number of directions on how you can
actually do this in the context of
precision medicine population health
biotechnology and agriculture or space
and astrobiology
so the first step here is going to start
with an overview of the general
background how to do literature review
identify different things that people
have already done to select something
that is still unanswered or maybe
there's a gap in research or maybe a
debate and controversy and how to use
that process of literature review to be
able to identify a very specific
question that you would like to focus on
once we do that then we have a very
well-defined process that will include
weekly meetings
submitting a form about your progress
keeping a journal of your progress from
learning to identifying your research
project to then conducting the analysis
and eventually working with the
community of both mentors and other
participants to go through that whole
process and submit the project and the
project will first of all be submitted
on the portal so on the portal
after you complete your profile
and uh you you know that is free you can
just complete your profile
and update it
you will then be able to
start working on a project after you
have 10 000 points and so that's where
the training comes in so you still in
the context of this program will have to
go through some training and importantly
we have another project that is designed
to guide you through the different steps
of literature review
identifying data sets on public
repositories like ncbi and then working
through your analysis
once you have done that you will be able
to fill in sections of a project from
title to abstract to methodology etc and
along the way get guidance from our
mentors that will help refine and kind
of accelerate that process for you
and we have a number of individuals that
have completed the research fellowship
they have either submitted a pre-print
in the con in the course of the three
months of that program
some of them have went on to then
publish so again i've been talking about
undergraduate students here or even have
used their
results in an ongoing research study
that they're involved in
or just generally use this
all right guys let's wait for
ellie i believe uh he got disconnected
one
i mean sorry don't know what happened
but um in any case i was close to the
end uh so um if anyone has any questions
about these programs
going to be available to answer those
questions or meet with you to discuss
your specific objectives
we do have a couple of minutes left here
so if you do have any questions here i'd
be happy to answer those
and parissa here is saying that you
qualify through ideas so again i want to
yeah briefly show you
what will happen
once you are registered
okay so
uh let's say for example you are
interested in biomedical data analysis
using r
and python
yes it's great question right carol how
do you know so this is a page where
again i'll just go to my profile
so this is my profile and you see that
under badges i have a number of programs
that i have been added to
and i also have a starter subscription
so once you pre-register right the
preview registration was when you filled
out the form and you said you know i'm
from this university this is my degree
this is which program i would like to
join once you fill out that form you are
now ready for registration and then uh
jabs or someone else will reach out to
you
ask specific questions if you do qualify
you will receive an email so you have
between now and june 15th to be fully
registered
and how do you know that you have been
registered you've received an email and
for that please make sure that you have
our contacts in your contact book so
they're not going to spam
those include hello at pine.bio
support
at pine.bio
so they're all going to be uh pine dot
bio accounts and they will notify you
that you have been accepted
and then you will see a
badge right here
with the description of the program that
you are
in
and you will get a starter subscription
so if you go to your profile again how
do you get to your profile you go in the
menu and click on your email address
and then you will see a program page
and the program page this is a program
page that i am not a part of so here you
will still request more information or
start your application if you scroll
down you will see here
uh pricing but if you have been accepted
you're not going to see pricing anymore
and i will show you that in a second but
this is an example of a program page it
has
a schedule of sessions
in each session you have additional
resources that you can complete
and um it's got a full overview of these
right here on top
if i go to a page
where i have uh
where i'm already a member of that
program you know i'll just go to this
one
in here i am already a member so i will
see it like this
and here you can see that i see my
personal progress
i have access to the coursework
and instead of just seeing a schedule i
see the session video if it already
passed that's the previous one or for
future ones i will see a zoom link and i
can click on that zoom link and i
actually participate in that zoom on the
specific date and time
so here um i can also complete sessions
and once i complete them
once i complete all of them
i will get the certificate
for
completing that program
any other questions
okay so if you qualify through lbrn do
you register for the classes via ilab
for hana i think that is uh for you
i think for lbr ren
you actually
uh yes for lvrn
um
you would have to go to
this link
to this registration link again this is
just for people who are from lbirn
and once you submit this uh form you
will be you will
be evaluated by
dr ramesh dubromanian
who is the program coordinator and he
will
or director and he
if you are approved then you will
receive an email notification from
either ramesh subramanian
you just joined we had a full webinar
already we're just about to um
by when are you supposed to get there
okay sorry for hana um
foreign would you like to go over this
thing again
can you repeat the question
the q there are two questions so the
first one is if we qualify through lvrn
do we register for the classes via ilab
and the second one was by when are we
supposed to get the notification
okay so if you are part of the lvrn
the
the form that you can see right now here
on the screen is the red cap
applications form i guess yeah so
just fill out this and your if you are
approved
you will be notified by the by john i
guess
so there they have some criteria it's
it's uh
the registration is free for a limited
number of
lvrn members so not all of
lbrn members will be um actually
getting the
free registration
offer
so um john and ramesh will be um
looking at your application and
if you qualify then you will be approved
and they will notify you and if you are
approved you will get an email from me
uh explaining the ilab registration
process so so far i already got 20
approved lprn members either faculty or
staff or students
so they i i guess the registration
process is over
but you can still contact and try to
fill out this form see whether they have
any um
any more spots available so yes first
free registration through this
registration form and then
fill out the forms in ilab
to get your registration completed so
two steps
so that's all right
hello
thank you dr farana
you are
i can can you hear me
yes i hear you
okay so the answer was clear right yep
okay
thank you for those information and uh i
guess that that wraps up our
presentation today
um
we would like to thank you for
uh to each and everyone who has taken
their time to join the webinar today
feel free to reach out if you have any
further questions and for those who are
interested feel free to email hello pine
dot bio
and also we will send a
follow-up email here shortly with the
with the link for the uh for today's
webinar
thank you guys
you